es que siempre te mantienes alerta.
Nada se da por sentado.
Viajar para mí es un poco como estar enamorado,
porque de repente todos tus sentidos se "encienden".
De repente estás alerta a los patrones secretos del mundo.
El verdadero viaje de descubrimiento, como famosamente dijo Marcel Proust,
no consiste en ver paisajes nuevos,
sino en ver con ojos nuevos.
Y, por supuesto, una vez que ves con ojos nuevos
hasta los viejos paisajes y tu hogar
se vuelven algo diferente.
Muchas de las personas que no viven en sus propios países
son refugiados que nunca quisieron dejar sus hogares
y anhelan volver a su hogar.
Pero para los afortunados entre nosotros,
creo que la era de la movilidad nos trae emocionantes posibilidades nuevas.
Es cierto que cuando viajo,
especialmente a las principales ciudades del mundo,
el personaje típico que llego a conocer hoy día
es, por ejemplo, una mujer mitad coreana y mitad alemana
que vive en París.
Tan pronto la joven conoce a ese chico mitad tailandés
y mitad canadiense de Edimburgo,
reconoce sus semejanzas.
Se da cuenta de que probablemente tiene mucho más en común con él
que con alguien totalmente coreano o alemán.
Así que se hacen amigos; se enamoran.
Se mudan a la ciudad de Nueva York.
(Risas)
O Edimburgo.
Y la niña que nace de esa unión
no será, por supuesto, ni coreana ni alemana,
ni francesa ni tailandesa, ni escocesa ni canadiense,
ni incluso estadounidense, sino una mezcla maravillosa
y constante de todos esos sitios.
Y posiblemente, la manera
en que esta joven mujer sueñe,
escriba, y piense acerca del mundo
pueda ser algo diferente,
porque surge a partir de una mezcla de culturas
sin precedentes.
De dónde eres es mucho menos importante
que hacia dónde vas.
Más y más de nosotros estamos tan enraizados al futuro
o al presente, como al pasado.
Y sabemos que el hogar no es el sitio
donde nos tocó nacer.
Es el sitio donde nos convertimos en lo que somos.
Mas aún, hay un gran problema con la movilidad
y es que es difícil saber cómo comportarse
cuando estás en el aire.
Hace unos años atrás me di cuenta de que había acumulado
un millón de millas solamente con United Airlines.
Todos Uds. conocen ese descabellado sistema
de pasar seis días en el infierno y el séptimo te sale gratis.
(Risas)
Comencé a pensar que realmente
la movilidad es tan buena como el sentido de quietud
que eres capaz de darle para ponerla en perspectiva.
Ocho meses después de la destrucción de mi casa
me encontré con un amigo que enseñaba en una escuela secundaria cercana
que me dijo: "Conozco el sitio perfecto para tí".
"¿De veras?" le dije. Siempre soy un poco escéptico
cuando la gente me dice cosas así.
"No, en serio", continuó,
"queda a solo tres horas en auto,
no es muy caro
y, posiblemente, no se parezca a ninguno de los sitios en los que has estado".
"Mmm". Comenzaba a intrigarme un poco. "¿Qué es?"
"Bueno..." --aquí mi amigo comenzó a vacilar--.
"Bueno, es una ermita católica".
No fue una buena respuesta.
Con haber pasado 15 años en escuelas anglicanas,
ya tenía himnos y cruces suficientes para toda una vida.
De hecho, varias vidas.
Pero mi amigo me aseguró que no era católico,
así como tampoco la mayoría de sus estudiantes,
pero todas las primaveras llevaba allí a sus alumnos.
Y allí, hasta el más inquieto y distraído
chico californiano de 15 años lleno de testosterona,
solo tenía que pasar tres días en silencio
y algo en él se tranquilizaba y se purificaba.
Se encontraba a sí mismo.
Así que pensé: "Todo lo que funciona con un chico de 15 años
debe funcionar conmigo".
Así que me subí al auto y manejé tres horas hacia el norte
junto a la costa,
y las vías se iban vaciando y estrechándose
hasta convertirse en un camino aún más estrecho,
apenas pavimentado y lleno de curvas por más de 3 km
hasta la cima de la montaña.
Y cuando salí del auto
el aire vibraba.
Todo el sitio estaba en silencio absoluto,
pero el silencio no implicaba la ausencia de ruido.
Era la presencia de un tipo de energía o vibración.
Y a mis pies se encontraba el grandioso y tranquilo paisaje azul
del océano Pacífico.
A mi alrededor había más de 300 Ha de arbustos silvestres secos.
Así que bajé al cuarto en el que dormiría.
Pequeño, pero maravillosamente cómodo,
con una cama, una mecedora,
un largo escritorio, y unas ventanas aún más largas
apuntando a un jardín pequeño y privado rodeado de paredes,
y unos 365 metros de grama de pradera dorada
extendiéndose hacia el mar.
Y me senté y comencé a escribir.
Y escribí y escribí,
aún cuando realmente había ido para alejarme de la escritura.
Cuando me levanté ya habían pasado cuatro horas.
Había caído la noche,
salí y me arropó un gran manto de estrellas,
y podía ver las luces de los autos
desaparecer alrededor del promontorio, casi 20 Km al sur.
Y realmente parecía que todas mis preocupaciones del día anterior
se desvanecían.
El próximo día cuando desperté,
ante la ausencia de teléfonos, televisiones y portátiles,
el día parecía extenderse por miles de horas.
Era realmente la libertad que experimentaba cuando viajaba,
aunque también lo sentía profundamente como una vuelta al hogar.
Y como no soy religioso
no asistí a los servicios.
No fui con los monjes para que me guiaran.
Solo daba largos paseos por el camino del monasterio
y enviaba postales a mis seres queridos.
Observaba las nubes,
e hice realmente lo que usualmente para mi es lo más difícil de hacer,
que es hacer nada.
Y comencé a regresar a este sitio,
y me di cuenta que era donde hacía mi trabajo más importante,
sin notarlo, y solo con quedarme quieto.
Y ciertamente tomar las decisiones más importantes
de la forma que nunca hubiese podido cuando estoy corriendo
del último correo electrónico a la próxima diligencia.
Y comencé a pensar que algo en mí
realmente había comenzado a gritar pidiendo quietud,
pero claro que no podía oírlo
porque estaba corriendo demasiado.
Era como un loco a quien le ponen una venda
y luego se queja de que no puede ver.
Y recordé esa frase maravillosa
de Séneca que había aprendido de niño
que dice: "El hombre es pobre
no porque tiene poco, sino porque anhela tener más".
Claro que no estoy sugiriendo
que todos aquí vayan a un monasterio.
Ese no es la cuestión.
Pero pienso que cuando dejas de moverte
es cuando puedes ver hacia dónde vas.
Y solo cuando te apartas de tu vida y del mundo,
puedes ver lo que realmente es importante
y conseguir un hogar.
He notado que muchos ahora
toman la decisión consciente de sentarse en silencio por 30 minutos
cada mañana para ordenar sus pensamientos
en un rincón del cuarto sin sus aparatos,
o se van a correr todas las tardes,
o dejan sus teléfones móviles
cuando van a pasar un buen rato conversando con un amigo.
La movilidad es un privilegio fantástico
y nos permite hacer muchas de las cosas que nuestros abuelos
nunca hubiesen soñado hacer.
Pero básicamente, la movilidad,
solo tiene sentido si tienes un hogar al cual regresar.
Y el hogar, al fin y al cabo, está
no solo en el sitio en donde duermes.
Es el sitio en donde estás.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)